Alerte ! Benett Foddy vient de sortir un nouveau jeu.
C'est qui euh?
B-Benett Foddy?
Le créateur de qwop et de clop.
Les amis,
j'aimerais que tout le monde garde son calme, aujourd'hui on va essayer de pas paniquer. On va jouer à un jeu
extrêmement dûr qui s'appelle Getting Over It.
Littéralement la traduction de
*Son du clavier*
darüber hinwegkommen. Euh... Se remettre. J'préférais la version allemande. C'est extrêmement simple c'est un jeu nous allons jouer
un monsieur qui est dans un pot et qui possède un marteau *rire*
Le but est très simple, c'est comme dans qwop et dans clop, il faut avancer, voilà,
et arriver au bout de la map. C'est parti, sans plus tarder, commençons à rager !
Alors comme d'hab la première difficulté ça va être quoi ? Ca va être d'intégrer les contrôles, c'est toujours...
Il est où le mec?
* Coucou !*
Squeezie : Waaaaaaaouh ...
Alors on dirait pas, mais en vrai le jeu est hyper bien fait.
Il va falloir intégrer la physique du jeu pour pouvoir passer les niveaux
Donc vous voyez on peut se déplacer comme ça grace à notre petit marteau
Alors le but de ce jeu est littéralement de te mettre à bout hein c'est a dire que le mec l'a dit lui même
PUTAIN !!
Est ce qu'on peut pas peter l'arbre ?
J'ai trop joué à minecraft
OH
C'est de la merde ce que j'ai fait mais je suis content !
Ok
Putain !
Arrête avec ta musique classique là tu me stresse
Je lis pas ce que tu dis
Parce que en fait je parle français je parle pas anglais et je veux juste-
NOOON !!
BOOM !
Ah mais je troll le jeu
Oh mais c'est trop facile ce jeu
C'EST TROP FACILE
Ok la difficulté en fait c'est de se démerder pour pas retourner en arrière
Parce que en fait tu contrôle rien de ce que tu fais alors que tu fais genre tu contrôles ce que tu fais
NON !
AAH j'arriverais à faire ce jeu !
Je m'en bas les couilles
Alors là c'est dur, en fait là je pense que c'est une situation adéquate pour prendre le temps de réfléchir
*M'en bas les couilles frère*
Oooh
Non non non
NON !
*pleurs*
N'hésitez pas si un ami à vous passe vraiment une mauvaise journée, à lui envoyer cette video
Et à lui dire regarde mec ta vie elle est pas si terrible
Putain
Oh ! Ah c'est tellement skillé ce que je viens de faire
Là, là il faut réfléchir.
NON!
Oh c'était pas loin !
NON !
NON!
À chaque fois !
Doucement doucement doucement doucement
Ok là mec on peut le faire
Concentration attention!
C'est bon ! c'est bon !
Attend il faut pas revenir en arrière attend qu'est ce que je fais ?
OH OH OH OH!
Je sais plus quoi faire !
Oh !
YES !
Attend mais mec là on a atteint un summum dans la difficulté
Comment je passe ça là je comprends pas, il faut se jeter
Ah ok de là
Ooooh
Non mais regarde où je reviens putain
NOOOON !
Yes ! allez on y arrive
OH!
Non je veux pas tomber je veux pas tomb- NOOON !
Alors, comment on monte ça ?
Ah mais en fait faut se pousser de l'autre j'ai compris
Faut aller sur celui là
Je vous le dis hein, si vraiment je retourne à gauche je fais une depression nerveuse sous vos yeux en direct
OH ! La vie est dure !
On peut s'en servir pour faire ça voilà
YES ! WOUH !
Les amis je viens de comprendre qu'en fait ici il y a un trou
Voila je pensais que c'était plein mais en fait c'est pas plein, je suis juste débile
À mon avis il faut s'accrocher aux putain de lampe
OH !
Attend il s'agit de pas tout gâcher maintenant
Putain c'est tellement dur, ya pas d'espace pour manipuler ce marteau !
OOOH
Qu'est ce qu'on fait ? j'ai l'impression d'avoir fini le jeu
Oh c'est comme ça ! Mec mec mec ! Respirez plus respirez plus
Y'en a un qui a respiré c'est pour ça
Vas-y Maintenant yes !
YES ! Yes j'ai envie de pleurer ! Oh mais vous imaginez pas ça fait 43 min !
Aller on continue
'Tain quand on avance bien comme ça je suis vraiment heureux
Et je suis tellement heureux qu'on pert toute la progression d'un coup !
On est chauds, on se remet dans le bain, dans le bain des gens qui ont confiance en eux
Apres tout on a fini Dark Souls 3 et c'était le plus dur de tous
C'est bon on a réussi ok alors la suite qu'est ce que c'est
Alors là ce qui est chaud c'est que si on tombe, je crois on retombe au tout debut du jeu en fait
je crois que c'est ca la blague hein
On escalade, on escalde, je comprends pas trop le decor mais on est pas mal
Ohlalalalalala c'est dingue
Ok. C'est pas grave on analyse le parcours, c'est normal de faire des petites erreurs
Pour moi là on est en train d'analyser le parcours on est hyper bien vous voyez ?
Mais c'est pas possible ce qu'il bien de se passer, c'est pas réel
C'est dans ma tête ça existe pas
Il s'est passé quoi vous sur vos écrans là ?
Non mais vraiment ?
Bah voila ça y est.
Yes ! Wouhou
Allez cette fois on y va on est déchainés
Par contre si je retombe c'est quand même du foutage de gueule,
c'est à dire que je suis sûr que y'a pas un gameplay youtube où un mec est tombé de cette manière
Vraiment je sais pas pourquoi je sens que y'a eu une sorte de bug
Oh putain !
Pardon pardon c'est faux
Attendez parce que quand je parle en fait je contrôle mal ma masse c'est incroyable !
Je parle pas de ma masse musculaire parce que j'ai pas besoin de la controller vu que y'en a pas
Pa-pa-pala-pala-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa-pala-pala-pa-pa-pa-pa
Yes
Yes yes cool
Non mec je refuse de vous pondre un gameplay aussi nul
Je veux au mois arriver au bout du niveau d'après quoi
Mais au final regardez c'est ce que je disais, on a galéré a passer ce premier level
Mais maintenant qu'on a intégré la technique et bah on galère plus trop
Voila et pourquoi j'ai dis ça je vais encore me faire fouetter par le putain de karma
C'est incroyable C'EST INCROYABLE !
Mais quand tu crois que t'es au plus bas ben t'es pas au plus bas ! En fait ya toujours plus bas
Oh je postillone comme un sagouin
J'en peux plus mec je suis le pire joueur
Juste je craque nan mais vraiment là je suis pas bien, nerveusement je suis pas bien!
Ok les amis là par contre je vais pas vous mytho,
À chaque fois vous le savez pas mais à chaque fois c'est 10 putains de minutes de rage
Pour revenir à ce putain d'endroit
Mais alors je vais vous dire un truc
Le pire dans tout ça c'est que je rage comme un porc, comme jamais
C'est à dire que je n'ai jamais aussi peu avancé en 1h15 sur un jeu
Je sais que vous avez eu très peur
La vérité c'est que moi aussi
YES ! Yes je détournais l'attention de ce jeu de merde en faisant une blague nulle pour pouvoir gagner
Alors attends
OH ! j'ai rien compris
Mais tout ce que je sais c'est que j'ai les larmes aux yeux et que là on est en train d'y arriver
AAAAH
Les amis je vous jure que j'aurais essayé. Je vous jure que j'aurais essayé mais là je faiblis
Je n'arrive plus à rien
Oh putain mais regardez c'est fou !
Le jeu m'indique qu'il faut que j'arrête !
J'ai plus le mouvement l'ai perdu le moulinet, j'ai perdu le moulinet
C''est comme un mec qui pas fait de vélo pendant 10 ans bah quand il remonte dessus bah..
Il sait en faire, mauvais exemple
Je crois que le mire c'est de se dire que j'ai réussi à les passer une fois et que là j'y arrive plus, je suis une énorme merde
Toute la france me regarde en mode
Mais putain mais c'est chiant ta video
Et que moi je les regarde et je leur dit bah ouais mais aussi mes parents ils m'ont pas fait fort aux jeux videos
OH PUTAIN !
Mais non vas y là mais là
Putaiiin....
Aller vas-y le casque ça dégage je m'en bas les couilles maintenant j'y vais
*Mec qui parle en japonais*
PUTAIN
Putain le mec en japonais qui parlait il avait raison !
Faut juste persévérer
Putain putain putain ! Comment j'ai fait ?
Mec mec, on a réussi ?
Non !
Alors ça y est on a passé le level ?
NON !
Sous-titres : Helialørea Ø  Twitter : claiirego